THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERNIAS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
POWER QUE HAN BENNETT. BERMAN
LOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHEN CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA MIKE FONG VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GRAY GRAYSON HANEY HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI THIS
AREA WHEN. DONALD PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH STONE
TAKING RELATIVE ERRORS THE
APPROVED ROCK VOEPEL WALDRON
WORD WEBER WICKS WILSON WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS IN THE GALLERY
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
IMAM YASIR KHAN. SHE. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY GOD
YOU ALONE UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFICULTIES AND HARDSHIPS OF
THESE MEN AND WOMEN. WHO SERVE
YOU AND OUR STATE. YOU ALONE
UNDERSTAND THE WEIGHT OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES BOTH PERSONAL
AND PROFESSIONAL WHICH THEY MUST
CARRY. YOU ALONE KNOW OF THE
PRIVATE SACRIFICES. WHICH YOUR
SERVANTS HERE BORE AND THEIR
PURSUIT OF SERVING THE STATE. I
ASK THAT YOU BLESS TO WATCH OVER
THEM AND THEIR FAMILIES
STRENGTHEN THEM WITH COURAGE AND
PEACE. MAY BE IN DOUBT ABOVE ALL
THINGS WITH YOUR SOVEREIGN GRACE
AND WISDOM I MEAN. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS MEMBERS REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US IN THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAYES AS HE LEADS WITH US IN THE
PLEDGE. READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER
GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY TRIM
SACRAMENTO PUT THURSDAY APRIL
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TO
THE ASSEMBLY MINUTE NINETY ON
THE HONORABLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE YOU RECENTLY
PRESIDING CHEAPER TO PROGRAM A
TEST REPORT DAVID. HARD MOVES
AND MISTER. SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS ND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED MMHM
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOVING TO
MOTIONS. AND RESOLUTIONS. THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ASPIRIN.
ON BEHALF OF MISS DOLLY THE L.
WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME RYAN
OSBORNE FROM FALL RIVER A TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SEPT STATE SCHOLAR
ATHLETE AWARD WINNER IN THE
GALLERY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER STRIKE
THAT. I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE
RULES TO ALLOW ALL BILLS HEARD
BY THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
TODAY THURSDAY MAY NINETEENTH
AND SUBSEQUENTLY REPORTED TO THE
DUST TODAY OR FRIDAY MAY
TWENTIETH. MONDAY MAY TWENTY
THIRD OR TUESDAY MAY TWENTY
FOURTH TO BE ORDERED TO THE
SECOND OR THIRD READING FILE OR
TO THE FIRST DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR ONE LEGISLATIVE DAY
PRIOR TO THE DAY REQUIRED UNDER
THE ASSEMBLY RULES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE. SB
NOT SB FORTY NINE- BURKE FROM
THE REVENUE TAXATION COMMITTEE
TO THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. SB EIGHT FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR ALLEN FOR THE CHURCH
COMMITTEE TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND THE
HOUSING AND COMMUTATIVE ALMOND
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA
THE TWO FOUR DAY FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO HEAR
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ODAY UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION IN ROOM.
ELEVEN HUNDRED AT TEN TWENTY
ONE- ST I ASKED THE CLERK READ
THE LIST OF BILLS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN TWENTY
AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN TWENTY THREE PROBLEMS
CYNICAL SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR
ROBERT. WHEN ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY TWENTY NINE VOEPEL
CYNICAL SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
HOLDEN CYNICAL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT CRISTINA GARCIA SENATE
BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY STONE SOME
PEOPLE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY THREE
QUIRK-SILVA SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY NINE CHOI SOME PEOPLE
EIGHTEEN NINETY FIVE EDUARDO
GARCIA ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
NINETY SIX QUART SOME PEOPLE
NINETEEN ELEVEN GABRIEL TO
MICHAEL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
PETRIE-NORRIS SOME OF OUR-
THIRTY ARAMBULA. TEAM THIRTY ONE
LIVES WITH US SOME PEOPLE
NINETEEN FORTY SALAS ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN FORTY ONE SALAS
CYNICAL NINETEEN FORTY EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
GRAYSON SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WILSON SOME OF THE
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AS AREA SO WE WILL
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT LORD SOME
PEOPLE NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
SANTIAGO SO WE WILL NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT SMITH. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO THOUSAND TO BE APPROVED
WHAT'S IN THE BILL TWENTY ELEVEN
WEEKS ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
NINETEEN PETRIE-NORRIS SO WE
WILL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR FRIEDMAN
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TWENTY NINE
WICKS SO MICHAEL TWENTY THIRTY
TWO WOULD WANT OTHER SEO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY FOUR
O'DONNELL SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FORTY TO THE VALLAPUDUA.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
LOW SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHTY
BOARD SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHTY
NINE BALCONY HERE AND SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
CARILLO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE
SIXTEEN MCCARTY SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE TRONG
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE THIRTY
ONE DOLLAR SOME EOPLE TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR THE WEBER SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO
GABRIEL SO MICHAEL TWENTY ONE
FIFTY THREE ARAMBULA. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
MARCO RUBIO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY SIX GRAYSON ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
WICKS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED ARAMBULA SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY TWO A ONE MINUE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY TWO ELEVEN TEAM
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THIRTEEN
AGUIAR-CURRY SOME OF THE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY SIX OF OUR TESTS SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY TO THIRTY TWO
MCCARTY. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TO
THIRTY THREE QUIRK-SILVA SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY TO FORTY TWO
SANTIAGO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD SYMBOL TWENTY
TO SEVENTY SIX CARILLO ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY TWO EIGHTY ONE
LACKEY SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TWO
NINETY EIGHT MAYES SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED CALL US AND
WE WILL TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN
BOARD SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE THREE OF US SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY THREE SIXTY ARAMBULA SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY THREE SIXTY THREE
MEAL BONTA SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX PETRIE-NORRIS
ASSEMBLY WILL. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT OR ONE SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FOUR TO WALK AWAY. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY TWENTY. SO WE WILL
TWENTY FOURTH EIGHT FREE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY THIRTY NINE
BLOOM SOME PEOPLE TO FOUR FOR
FOUR JUMP SAWYER. ASSEMBLY
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY.
SO FAR. SOME PEOPLE TO FOUR
SEVEN AS A- ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY FIVE QUIRK-SILVA.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY
ARAMBULA SYMBOL TWENTY FOUR
NINETY ONE CERVANTES. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR AND YOU KNOW
I MAIENSCHEIN SO WE WILL TWENTY
FIVE FOURTEEN MAKING DALY. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN ME
A BONTA. ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWO GREAT SYMBOL
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY NINE DAVIES.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE COURT SO WE WILL TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT CUNNINGHAM.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
ONE SALAS SO WE WILL TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN. AND WATER GARCIA
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE NINETY
ARAMBULA SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE
NINETY FOURTEEN SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SEVEN BLOOM.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT AKITA WEBER SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN RODRIGUEZ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWO MULLIN SO WE WILL TWENTY SIX
TWENTY FOUR KALRA. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SIX THIRTY O'DONNELL SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY SIX THIRTY EIGHT
PLUMAS SYMBOL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
ONE PETRIE-NORRIS. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SIX FIFTY TWO MCCARTY
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIX FOR THREE
SANTIAGO. ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
SIX SIXTY THREE RAMOS SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY SIX SIXTY SIX L.
AS- A SYMBOL TWENTY SIX SEVENTY
ONE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
SIX SEVENTY THREE OR ONE
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS. SOME PEOPLE WENTY
SIX EIGHTY SIX COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS. ASSEMBLY
WILL TWENTY SIX NINETY FIVE
BERMAN ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
SEVEN OH TO GIPSON SYMBOL TWENTY
SEVEN FIVE QUIRK-SILVA. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY FOUR
ARAMBULA SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY WANTING SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT REYES.
WE WILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX
FRIEDMAN. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY EIGHT HOLDEN SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE
EDUARDO GARCIA. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE REYES
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
FIVE PURSUE TEA. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE SANTIAGO
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
WALDRON SYMBOL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY RECUPERA. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR KEY
THE WEBER SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX STONE. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN NINETY FOUR
GIPSON SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT
OH SIX MARCO RUBIO. A SIMPLE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN REYES SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN
WALDRON. SOME THIRTY TWO
ROBERT RIVAS SIMPLE TWENTY FIFTY
WHITE WATER. GARCIA SOME PEOPLE
TO THE EIGHT SIXTY FOUR ROBERT
RE. SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVENTY
THREE. SAWYER SO WILL TWENTY
EIGHT A- ME UP. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. SOME PEOPLE
TO EIGHT EIGHTY. OF ONE GARCIA.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT
NINE WE- ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY
NINETY THREE. ASSEMBLY TWENTY
NINETY FONG. ASSEMBLY TWENTY
NINE LEVEN. ASSEMBLY WILL
TWENTY NINE TWENTY ARAMBULA SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY NINE TWENTY
UNDERWATER GARCIA. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE- DAHLE
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE THIRTY
SEVEN CALDERONE. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINE FORTY NINE ONLY
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY NINE FIFTY
GRAYSON WILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
FOUR COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
AND- ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY FOUR COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHERE'S YOUR RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THERE ARE NINE BILLS ON
FILE WITH FLOOR AMENDMENTS
PENDING AT THE DESK FOR ADOPTION
TODAY. I ASKED THE CLERK READ
BILL THOSE ITEMS AND THAT WOULD
THEN ADOPT THE FLOOR AMENDMENTS
WITH A SINGLE VOICE VOTE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE- BILL'S.
SIXTY A SYMBOL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN KALRA ITEM SIXTY NINE OF
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE OF SEVEN
FLOOR ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY EIGHTY FIVE
HOLDEN ITEM NINETY NINE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE
KALRA. ITEM ONE OF FORCING THE
BILL EIGHTEEN ELEVEN MIKE FONG I
DON'T WANT TO RISE IN THE BILL
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR COURT ITEM
ONE THIRTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINETY SEVEN FRIEDMAN
ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
COURT. AND ITEM ONE THIRTY TO
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
DODD BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO. MEMBERS WE WE'RE TAKING A
VOICE VOTES ON THE BACKS
AMENDMENTS- PREVIOUSLY READ BY
THE CLERK. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILLS
ARE OUT TO PRINCE IN BACK OUTON
FILE.
MAJORITY LEADER REYES YOUR
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. AS
YOU KNOW WE'RE SUFFERING A POWER
OUTAGE. HERE IN THE CAPITAL WE
ARE. WE ARE WORKING WITH
GENERATORS ON BY OUR BORROWED.
POWER THE SCHEDULE FOR TODAY IS
GOING TO BE SHORTENED PURSUANT
TO THE SPEAKER'S REQUEST AND WE
WILL TAKE CARE OF A FEW MATTERS-
I ASK FOR YOU THE TO GIVE THE
PRESIDING OFFICER YOUR-
ATTENTION SO WE CAN GET THROUGH
THIS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
THANK YOU. WE WILL NEVER MOVE
NOW TO THE THIRD READING.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE VOTE WE WILL FIRST
TAKE UP ANY RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDING ON ANY CO AUTHORS. AND
IN. THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN
RELATIVE TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS
WEEK SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY FIVE BY SERVER
WIENER AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
DAY SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
96% OF MEN AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO ANNIVERSARY OF LOS ANGELES
RIGHTS AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY NINE BY CENTER
OCHO POPE AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
TAKE OUR DAUGHTERS AND SONS TO
WORK DAY.
THE CLERK WILL NOWOPEN THE ROLE
TO ALLOW. THERE IS TO THE
RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS THIS STATE
IS FOR CALL AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO DEVOTE.
MEMBERS IF YOU WISH TO ADD ON
YOUR NAME IS ACOSTA TO THE
RESOLUTION ON CONSENSUS PLEASE
VOTE NOW. GLOBAL CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SIXTY THREE CO AUTHORS.
MOVING TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE ANY ITEMS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND THEY CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
AND ACTIVE IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS WE DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL
AND TELL YOU TO VOTE. AND SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY SEVEN FIVE
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TO SIXTY SIX NO
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FORTY FOUR SIXTY SIX NOW IS
SIXTY EIGHT. SIXTY SIX THERE ARE
SOME OF THE TWENTY NINETY SIX
SIXTY SIX ZERO CYNICAL TWENTY
ONE. SIXTY SIX KNOWS THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE THIRTY I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR SIXTY
SIX ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
THREE FIFTY FIVE SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THREE
FIFTY EIGHT. SIXTY SIX ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SIXTY
SIX KNOWS THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FOUR THIRTEEN SIXTY SIX
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN. SIXTY SIX ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
WITH URGENCY SIX SIX NOW AT ZERO
AND THE URGENCY I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO. THE BOSTON SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY EIGHT OF SEVEN SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE
OH FOUR I SIXTY SIX ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY NINE FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO SOMETHING
TWENTY NINE FIFTY SIX. SIXTY SIX
NO ARE SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE
SIXTY ONE FIFTY SIX ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE.
SIXTY SIX THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY THREE SIXTY
SIX ZERO SOME INCOME RESOLUTION
ONE EIGHTY. SIX ZERO SURGICAL
RESOLUTION NINETY FIVE. ZERO
SEVEN WAS LOSING NINETY SIX
SIXTY SIX ZERO WHO WAS. AND NINE
I THINK SIX ZERO INCIDENT
RESOLUTION ONE OF FOUR.I SIXTY
THREE NO.
ZERO
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW PRESENTED BY MISTER
WARD. HR ONE OH NINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORD ARE RECOGNIZED THE
CLERK WILL READ. POSTPOSITION
ONE OF NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
HARVEY MILK DAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OR DEAR RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER HOBBY
HARVEY MILK DAY I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LGBTQ
CAUCUS TO PRESENT HR ONE OH NINE
TODAY WE WILL HONOR HARVEY MILK
A HERO AND THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
HARVEY WAS THE FIRST OPENLY GAY
ELECTED OFFICIAL IN CALIFORNIA
AND IN ANY MAJOR UNITED STATES
CITY. HE'S A GLOBAL ICON AND A
PIONEER IN THE LGBTQ CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT. HARVEY OF
COURSE UNSUCCESSFULLY RAN IN
SEVERAL LOCAL ELECTIONS BUT HIS
PERSISTENCE PAID OFF IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WHEN HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. HIS
UNPRECEDENTED ELECTION VICTORY
AND THE WAVES HE MADE IN JUST
ONE YEAR CONTINUE TO INSPIRE US
TODAY AS WE INCREASE
REPRESENTATION ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THE COUNTRY AND THE WORLD.
WORKING TO FIGHT HOMOPHOBIA AND
OTHER FORMS OF LGBTQ
DISCRIMINATION MILK WAS OFTEN
THE LOUDEST VOICE AT A TIME WHEN
MANY WERE AFRAID TO BE
THEMSELVES. HE ACTIVELY
ENCOURAGED MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY THE SHOW PRIDE AND
EXPRESS THEIR TRUE IDENTITIES.
DURING HIS TERM ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HARVEY MILK
SPONSORED AND SUCCESSFULLY PASS
A GAY RIGHTS ORDINANCE AND WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN DEFEATING
PROPOSITION SIX THE BRIGGS
INITIATIVE. AT THE GENERAL
ELECTION IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD HAVE BANNED
GAYS AND LESBIANS FROM TEACHING
IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS ACROSS OUR
STATE. HARVEY MILK WAS ALSO
SUCCESSFUL IN FORGING COALITIONS
IN SAN FRANCISCO'S OTHER
MINORITY LEADERS. HIS MESSAGE
WAS ONE OF UNITY AGAINST
OPPRESSION AND ALL OF ITS FORMS.
IN HIS GAY FREEDOM DAY SPEECH HE
SAID I CALL UPON ALL MINORITIES
AND ESPECIALLY THE MILLIONS OF
LESBIANS AND GAY MEN TO WAKE UP
FROM THEIR DREAMS. TO GATHER ON
WASHINGTON AND TELL THEIR NATION
WAKE UP. WAKE UP AMERICA NO MORE
RACISM NO MORE SEXISM NO MORE
AGES THEM NO MORE HATRED NO MORE
. HARVEYS LAKE WAS WAS OF COURSE
TRAGICALLY CUT SHORT AFTER A
FORMER COLLEAGUE ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ASSASSINATED HIM.
AND SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR GEORGE
MOSCONE. HARVEY'S KILLER WAS
CONVICTED OF MANSLAUGHTER
INSTEAD OF MURDER AND JUSTICE
THAT SPARKED RIOTS. THE OUTCOME
OF THAT TRIAL SERVES AS A STARK
REMINDER THAT WE MUST ALWAYS BE
VIGILANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
FAIRNESS AND EQUITY IS IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM. HI EVERYONE SAID
I KNOW THAT YOU CAN'T LIVE ON
HOPE ALONE BUT WITHOUT HOPE LIFE
IS NOT WORTH LIVING. AND IN A
WORLD WHERE WE HAVE YET TO
ENSURE EQUALITY FOR ALL HARRY'S
IMPACT AS A TRAILBLAZER AND
CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCATES. MOVES US
TO CONTINUE THE FIGHT AND FINISH
WHAT WE STARTED MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR ONE OH NINE. THANK
YOU MISTER WARD. THIS WILL SEND
YOUR RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT FOR HR
ONE OH NINE RELATIVE TO HARVEY
MILK DAY. LIKE MANY OF THE BLACK
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS WHO LED
MOVEMENTS FOR SOCIAL CHANGE
HARVEY MILK HAVE THE COURAGE TO
RISK HIS LIFE TO SERVE THOSE IN
NEED AND STAND UP TO THOSE
THREATENED BY CHANGE OF
CALIFORNIANS IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO HONOR THE LIFE
OF GREAT INDIVIDUALS LIKE HARVEY
MILK. AND BE MINDFUL OF THEIR
LESSONS OF COURAGE HUMILITY AND
SACRIFICE FOR EQUALITY AS A
PROUD MOTHER OF A MEMBER OF THE
LGBT PLUS COMMUNITY AND A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AN ALLY IN THE
FIGHT FOR FULL EQUALITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I AM HONORED TO
STAND IN RECOGNITION. OF THE
LIKE LIFE AND LEGACY OF HARVEY
MILK AND COMMEMORATE HIS DATE OF
BIRTH FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR HR WHEN A NINE. MEMBERS
LET'S DIRECT OUR ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GHADIR IT WAS
RECOGNIZED AT OUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF HR
ONE OR NINE COMMEMORATING HARVEY
MILK DAY AT A TIME WHEN LIVING
FREELY IN AUTHENTICALLY CARRIED
THE POTENTIAL OF PROFESSIONAL
SOCIAL OR EVEN LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES. AND THREATS TO
ONE'S PHYSICAL SAFETY HARVEY
MILK ADVOCATED TO CREATE SPACE
FOR LGBTQ PLUS AMERICANS IN
PUBLIC LIFE. LOVE IS LOVE IS
LOVE IS LOVE IS LOVE AND THE
RIGHT TO PRIVACY IS UNDER THREAT
WITH THE REPEAL OF ROE V. WADE
*** THE RIGHT TO MARRY WHOMEVER
YOU LOVE I'M PROUD TO RISE TODAY
AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND RECOGNIZED.
HARVEY MILK'S LIFE THE MOVEMENT
HE SPARKED HIS CONTRIBUTIONS AND
MEANING TO THE LATINO COMMUNITY
AS WELL AS THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
ALL LGBTQ PLUS LATINOS AND LGBTQ
PLUS CALIFORNIANS TO OUR STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISGUIDED
YOU MISTER LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE API CAUCUS HONOR
HARVEY MILK THE TRAILBLAZER FOR
THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY. WHEN
HARVEY MILK WAS ELECTED TO
BECOME A SAN FRANCISCO
SUPERVISOR NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN HE BECAME THE FIRST OPENLY
GAY MAN ELECTED TO THAT OFFICE
IN PUBLIC OFFICE IN CALIFORNIA.
HARVEY WAS NO STRANGER TO THE
API COOK COMMUNITY AND HE KNEW
THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING A
DIVERSE COALITION WITH OTHER
GROUPS INCLUDING THE ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO. THIS IS EVIDENT IN
HIS SUPPORT OF GORDON LAU WHO
BECAME SAN FRANCISCO'S FIRST
CHINESE AMERICANS A RISER
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. PRIOR TO
HARVEY SAID A DEATH HE WAS
QUOTED AS SAYING IF SAN
FRANCISCO'S ASIAN ENGAGE MEANS
CAN FIND A WAY TO UNITE. AND
WORK TOGETHER WILL HOLD ALL THE
CARDS. EXACTLY AFTER I BROKE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEE MISTER
HANEY ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
RISE TODAY AS THE REPRESENTATIVE
OF SAN FRANCISCO- HARVEY'S.
FORMER HOME- HE WAS A CHAMPION
FOR THE LGBT COMMUNITY BUT FOR
ALL PEOPLE AND HE SET UP FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS HE HAD A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON SAN FRANCISCO- IN IN
HIS LEADERSHIP- BUT HE BLAZED A
TRAIL FOR PEOPLE NOT ONLY IN OUR
STATE BUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I'M VERY PROUD TO REPRESENT A
STRONG AND THRIVING LGBTQ
COMMUNITY IN SAN FRANCISCO THAT
NOW GETS TO LIVE OPENLY AND
PROUDLY BECAUSE OF THE
LEADERSHIP AND EXAMPLE THAT
HARVEY SEN. I AM VERY PROUD TO
BE IN THIS CHAMBER REPRESENTING
THE CASTRO WHICH WAS HIS FORMER
HOME- AND ON BEHALF OF MY
DISTRICT AND ON BEHALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL I AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN SUPPORT OF HR
ONE ON NINE THANK YOU. SEEING
AND HEARING THE FOR THE DEBATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. APOLOGIES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MATTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS WANT
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR HIS VERY ELOQUENT
WORDS- WE JOIN CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS IN HONORING THE
TREMENDOUS CONTRIBUTIONS AND
LEGACY OF HARVEY MILK WHO IS NOT
ONLY A LEADER IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
AND HIS JEWISH IDENTITY SO
POWERFULLY INFORM THE WORK THAT
HE DOES HE DID. HIS BIOGRAPHER
RECOUNTS THAT AT ONE POINT- HE
THOUGHT ABOUT OPENING A JEWISH
DELI IN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
WOULD SAY WE ARE ALSO GLAD THAT
HE DIDN'T AND HE CHOSE TO TAKE
HIS TALENTS TO HELP CHANGE THE
WORLD HELP BLAZE A TRAIL FOR THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY A TO HELP CHANGE
OUR WORLD IT'S SUCH A POWERFUL
WAY SO WE STAND IN STRONG
SOLIDARITY WITH LGBTQ CAUCUS
WITH ALL OF THOSE TO HONOR. THE
MEMORY AND THE LEGACY OF THIS
REMARKABLE HUMAN BEING AND ON
BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. ON HR ONE OH NINE. THANK
YOU MR GABRIEL. MR WARD YOU
RECOGNIZE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
MESSAGE I WANT TO THANK ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS THE
STATE FOR YOUR KIND WORDS AND
YOUR SUPPORT YOUR POINTS THAT
YOU MADE IN THE MEMORY OF HARVEY
MILK WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR HIS
TRAILBLAZING EFFORTS BUT OF
COURSE WE WANT TO LIVE ON HIS
PRINCIPLES EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
ALTHOUGH WE GOT ALL THE ALL THE
GUIDANCE CITY GIVES US- IN THE
WORK THAT WE DO HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT I ENCOURAGE.
MEMBERS FROM ACROSS THE THIS A
GREAT STATE- TO TAKE HIS MESSAGE
HOME AS WE CELEBRATE HARVEY MILK
DAY THIS COMING WEEK TO YOUR
HOME DISTRICTS AND REMEMBER TO
ALL THOSE THAT ARE REALLY SCARED
THAT ARE REALLY- IN THE SHADOWS
TO COME OUT OF THE SHADOWS TO
LIVE TO BE THEIR TRUE SELVES AND
TO GIVE THEM HOPE YOU ARE THE
REPRESENTATIVES YOU ARE THE
LEADERS THAT CAN GIVE OUR YOUTH
AND OUR NEXT GENERATION THE HOPE
FOR A BRIGHTER FUTURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR COAUTHORS AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND
H. R. ONE ONLINE TODAY. WOULD
YOU LIKE THE FIRST REAL OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS. MR WARD HAS
REQUESTED THAT THE ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THAT
YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. THERE
ARE FIFTY THREE CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE SHALL NOT
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY NO. THE
AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING ON NOW TO THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS FORTY SEVEN
. THROUGH FIFTY NINE. THE FILE
ITEMS FORTY SEVEN THROUGH FIFTY
SHALL BE PASS AND RETAIN. FILE
ITEMS. FIFTY ONE THREE TWO.
SIXTY TWO CHEVY PASSWORD CHANGE. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN.
LARA. MR FLORI ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA MAC
LEADING TO ELECTIONS. MISTER
FLORIO RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE OH
SEVEN WILL PREVENT THOSE WHO ARE
LICENSED TO CONDUCT MOLECULAR
TESTING FOR HUMAN GENETICS TO
ALSO BE DONE FOR INFECTIOUS
DISEASE I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE. I HAVE A BETTER ONE.
SEVEN LARA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR AB. TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN.
SILICON MIL THAT PRESENTATION TO
. EUROPEAN THE CLERK WILL READ
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORIDA BLUE TO
ALEXION'S. ALL RIGHT TAKE TO
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN WITH WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL VOTING LOCATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR VOTERS AUTHORIZED
- COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
UTILIZE VENUES LIKE THE A HOLES
TO SERVICE POLLING LOCATIONS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE.
ALL THE V. EIGHT HAVING SEIZE
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. I SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES. I SIXTY THREE KNOWS TO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. I AM SIXTY
FOUR THROUGH SEVENTY EIGHT SHALL
BE PASS AND RETAIN. ITEM EIGHTY
SHALL BE PASSED ENTERTAINED.
LIVING ON TO I AM. ADAM NUMBER
EIGHTY ONE.
MOVING OUT ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE ACR ONE SEVENTY FOUR
BOERNER HORVATH. THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA TOURISM
MONTH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH THEY ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS ACR ONE SEVENTY
FOUR WOULD DECLARE MAY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS CALIFORNIA TOURISM
MONTH AND URGE CALIFORNIANS TO
SUPPORT TOURISM AND LOCAL
BUSINESSES BY TRAVELING IN STATE
AS AN ACT OF CIVIC PRIDE
CALIFORNIANS TRAVEL AND
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST ECONOMIC DRIVERS FOR
THE STATE AND NUMBER ONE IN THE
NATION IN TERMS OF VISITORS AND
VISITOR SPENDING. PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC IN TWENTY NINETEEN
VISITORS TO CALIFORNIA SPENT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS SPENDING THAT SUPPORT
OVER ONE POINT TWO MILLION JOBS
AND TWELVE POINT TWO BILLION IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES THE
PANDEMIC CUT TRAVEL AND
HOSPITALITY JOBS NEARLY IN HALF
AND WE LOST SEVENTY NINE POINT
EIGHT BILLION IN VISITOR
SPENDING IN TWENTY TWENTY A 55%
DECLINE. THE TOURISM SECTOR
BEGAN ITS RECOVERING LAST YEAR
BUT REMAINS WELL SHORT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN LEVELS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE VISITORS TO CAUSE BONTA
CALIFORNIA SPENT A HUNDRED POINT
TWO BILLION SPENDING THAT
SUPPORTED NINE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND JOBS AND NINE
POINT EIGHT BILLION IN STATE AND
LOCAL TAXES. ARE ICONIC GATEWAY
CITIES LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO AND CITIES WITH AN
ORANGE COUNTY HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT WITH A
DOWNTURN AND INTERNATIONAL
VISITORS AND CONVENTION BUSINESS
SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
RECORDED SIX POINT ONE BILLION
IN VISITOR SPENDING IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE JUST 43% OF THE
FOURTEEN POINT TWO BILLION
REGION TWENTY NINETEEN.
CALIFORNIA WILL NOTCOMPLETELY
RECOVER WITHOUT THE FULL RETURN
OF LEISURE AND BUSINESS TRAVEL
AS WELL AS A MEETINGS AND EVENTS
BUT BOTH DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL VISITORS AND TELL
THEN URGING CALIFORNIANS TO
SUPPORT TOURISM BY TRAVELING
WITHIN OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE AS AN
ACT OF CIVIC PRIDE WHEN ABLE OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE MUSEUMS ARE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS ARE CENTERS
TO CONTINUE RECOVERING BRING
BACK. JOBS AND ULTIMATELY HELP
TIRE STATES ECONOMIC REBOUND
FROM THE PANDEMIC. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AND THE FIRST WILL BE FOR
AUTHORS. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH BECAUSE THAT'S
THE FIRST REAL TO BE OPENS FOR
CO AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TODAY.
ALL MEMBERS THAT YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
ARE SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS ADDED. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL NOW
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY
NO THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO IS PASTOR
JAMES. FILE ITEMS. EIGHTY FOUR
TO NINETY TWO OUR PASSWORD
CHANGE WE WILL MOVE ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM NUMBERNINETY THREE AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH KERKORIAN
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
CANNABIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPENT
THE RECOGNIZED. THE SERVER
WORKING UP THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT.
OUR STATE IS DEALING WITH AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
CANNABIS GROWS. MORE THAN EVER
BEFORE THE PASSING OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR- WE ALLEVIATE THIS STRAIN
ON THE LEGAL MARKET IT IS
NECESSARY TO INCENTIVIZE
COMPLIANCE. ENSURE THAT NON
COMPLIANCE WILL BE FINANCIALLY
CUMBERSOME. AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT DOES EXACTLY THAT.
IT INCREASES THE COST BURDEN OF
FINES SIGNIFICANTLY ON ANY
OPERATION THAT CHOOSES TO REMAIN
IN NONCOMPLIANCE AND THEY SHOULD
SHOULDER THE COST. THE BILL
OFFERS AN AMNESTY PERIOD OF TWO
WEEKS THAT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE. THIS IS A
BUILDINGS THE IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD FIXING THE PITFALLS OF
LEGALIZATION. ENSURING THAT THE
VOTERS INTENDED OF A LEGAL
INDUSTRY TO THRIVE IN CALIFORNIA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER SMITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
RECOGNIZED. YEAH RESPECTFULLY-
MADAM CHAIR QUESTION TO THE
AUTHOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE HIGH
DESERT WE HAVE AN- EVER
INCREASING- PROBLEM WITH THIS-
ILLEGAL GROW SITUATION AND SO I
WAS VERY EXCITED TO SEE. THIS
MEASURE WHICH SEEMS TO FOCUS ON
PENALIZING THESE ILLEGAL GROWERS
ARE YOU TOOK A- AN AMENDMENT IN
JUDICIARY AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT AMENDMENT DOES
NOT DIMINISH FROM THAT THAT
INTENT YOU JUST INDICATED SO IF
YOU COULD JUST HELP ME
UNDERSTAND DEMAND THAT YOU TOOK
THERE. I'D BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT. M. THE AMENDMENT GIVES THEM
A WINDOW TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
IT DOES NOT CHANGE THE BILL AT
ALL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRKIER
RECOGNIZED. AW YES HI- I AM
WRITING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT- ONE OF THE
REASONS THERE'S A PROBLEM.
TEKELI IN THE HIGH DESERT IS A
ITS REMOTENESS BUT ALSO SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY HAS VERY FEW
CITIES THAT HAVE ALLOWED
CANNABIS- AND I HOPE THAT
CHANGES BECAUSE THAT'LL ALSO
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IF PEOPLE
CAN GET IT LEGALLY THEY'RE LESS
LIKELY TO GET IT ILLEGALLY. IN
THE MEANTIME THIS IS A GOOD STEP
OF THE WITH THE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE TAKEN THE
CANNABIS GROUPS NVOLVED
WITHDRAWN THEIR OPPOSITION AND I
HEARD YOU KNOW VOTE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FULLY RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
ACTUAL WANT TO BRING THE
ATTENTION OF THE HOUSE SURE THE
BACKSTORY TO HOW WE GOT TO A
BILL LIKE THIS YOU KNOW THE
VOTERS IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
APPROVED THE COMPASSIONATE USE
ACT IN CALIFORNIA. THIS DEALT
WITH MEDICAL MARIJUANA AND ONE
PASSED IN NINETY SIX THE ACT
SAID. THE LEGISLATURE. WILL COME
IN BEHIND THIS ACT PASSED BY
VOTERS AND ADOPT GUIDELINES. FOR
TWENTY YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
TOOK THAT ISSUE UP. DEBATED FOR
YEAR THE WHEELS CAME OFF THE
LAST MINUTE AND IT DIED. THIS
TRYING TO MAKE ANY FRAMEWORK FOR
MARIJUANA OF ANY TIME. IT WAS
LIKE GROUNDHOG DAY EVERY YEAR WE
RENEWED IT EVERY YEAR WE RENEWED
EVERY YEAR WE RENEW IT UNTIL
TWENTY OF FIFTEEN. WHEN AN
EFFORT WAS UNDERTAKEN IN THIS
BODY A BI PARTISAN EFFORT TO
TACKLE THIS ISSUE WHICH HAD BEEN
THIS ASTONISHING GORDON NOT A
PUBLIC POLICY. AND DOES HAVE
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE BECAUSE
WE GOT TOGETHER ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS PUT TOGETHER A PACKAGE.
STARTED MOVING AT THE SENATE
SORT OF FALL WHEN WE ALREADY DID
THE SAME THING. THEY JUST DIDN'T
HAVE THE HORSEPOWER DIDN'T I
HAVE THE BACK IN THAT HOUSE ON
THE DAY WHEN THE SENATE PACKAGE
GOT OUT WITH TWENTY ONE VOTES IT
PASSED OFF THIS FOR BIPARTISAN
SIXTY FOUR VOTES IN SUPPORT. AND
THAT ENERGIZED THE WHOLE SUING
DEBATE. SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THIS IS A RIGHTEOUS AMENDMENT.
THE BALLOT PROPOSITION DEAL WITH
CANNABIS MORE GENERALLY. WAS RE
WRITTEN TO REFLECT A LOT OF THE
APPROACH YOU CAME ON THE WHOLE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA BREAKTHROUGH
THAT THIS HOUSE CRITICALLY
INJURED HERE AND SO I THINK THIS
IS A GOOD THING BUT I WHAT WHAT
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS ASSEMBLY TO
REALIZE IT WAS THIS BODY. THAT
SET THE WHOLE CONVERSATION MOST
AFTER TWENTY YEARS OF FAILURE
AND WE DIDN'T COLLABORATIVELY ON
A BIPARTISAN BASIS- THANK YOU MR
COOLEY. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH YOU MAKE BOTH. THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS FROM MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WHAT THAT WORK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. FIFTY FOUR
VOTES FOR PASSAGE. ALL THOSE
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
I SIXTY NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
F. INTRODUCTIONS TO MAKE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE
PORTABLE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
THE GALLERY.
AND ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN AND IN THE GALLERY HAVE
SIXTH GRADE CLASSROOM AND WEBER
SCHOOL. ON IT WE ALSO HAVE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL THE FOURTH GRADE
STUDENTS FROM VALLEY BETH SHALOM
HAROLD M. CHEL WORK SHOW WAYS
DAY SCHOOL IN THE GALLERY. AND
FINALLY IN THE GALLERY AGAIN
RECOGNIZING OUR SIP STATE
SCHOLAR ATHLETE AWARD WINNER ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY
. MISTER RYAN OSBORNE.
SECOND READING THE COR GLORIA
SOME PEOPLE.
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE
SEVENTEEN OH FOUR SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FIVE EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN
NINETY FOUR NINETEEN NINETY ONE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO OH FIVE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR TWENTY TWO SIXTY
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
THIRTY FOUR TWENTY THREE THIRTY
NINE TWENTY THREE FIFTY NINE
TWENTY FOUR FORTY TWO TWENTY
FIVE OH THREE TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY TWO TWENTY SIX OF
SIX TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN OH
TWO TWENTY TWELVE TWENTY ONE
THIRTY NINE. 218-123-2620
330-234-0220 THREE TWENTY FORTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX OH FOUR TWENTY SIX
FIFTY FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
SIX TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY TWENTY ON
212-962-2960 SEVEN TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY ONE TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
TWO TWENTY SEVENTY WITH A
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FORTY FOR THE MINUTES. ALL BILLS
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED-
MOVING ON. WE CAN. ITEMS UNDER
CONSIDERATION SHALL BE CONTINUED. SENATE THIRD READING FILE
ITEMS ONE TWENTY NINETY ONE
THIRTY ONE SHALL BE PASS AND
RETAIN. WE HAVE DISPENSED WITH
ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO.
MEMBERS I'M ORDERING THE DEATH
TO BE HELD OPEN TO THE PROCESS
ANY COMMITTEE REPORTS. WE HAVE
ONE COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION
TODAY AND SWING SPACE ROOM
ELEVEN HUNDRED. IN THE ABSENCE
OF OBJECTION THAT THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.
MEMBERS THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY TWENTIETH
NO FLOOR SESSION IT NO CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY MAY TWENTY THIRD
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAINED ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS. MISS REYES
MOVES AND MISTER FLORES SECONDS
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY MAY TWENTY THIRD AT
ONE PM.